so you probably didn't expect me to give
the Christmas lecture I'm glad you all
came and in fact I will not be but I'm
just here to introduce done so it's a
real honor for me you know to have the
opportunity to introduce done
I think his accomplishments are probably
well known to the people in the audience
you know the work in programming
languages in computer theory algorithms
on on tech and and many other things you
know that extend way beyond computer
science I thought you know what could I
say that people would know and so I
thought I can't talk about my
experiences with done over the years and
so I just you know just a few brief
mentions of of how I've known done you
know through my career so I first met
him but only virtually when I was 20
years old and I got this book that I was
supposed to read on algorithms and I
could not believe the the amount of
material in that book and how anybody
could possibly know all this stuff and
then I found out there was more than one
book yeah and that really surprised me
so I thought I will never master all of
this material and and and then I
eventually realized that actually
probably Dawn's the only person who
knows everything in all of those books
you know at some point in my in my life
I realized that and then when I came to
Stanford in 2003 I actually got to meet
done in person we may have met earlier
than that may have crossed paths but
actually when I joined the department
you know Don was obviously a very senior
figure in the department and always had
kind words for for new people and so
that's why I actually got to know done
personally and and you know he did the
many kindnesses over the years I just
mentioned one my kids appear in one of
his books so so Don used my kids as
models in one of his books and there's
several pages and their photographs and
he gave us my wife and I a signed copy
of that book which we which we treasure
then there was an event maybe only three
or four years ago
when Don came into my office and said he
had read one of my papers he had this
technical question okay and you know
about this paper I'd written a couple
years before and being a slow thinker I
think I answered it extremely poorly on
the spot Don you know he had he had
actually studied the paper and
understood the issue at least as well as
I did at that point in time baby was
very generous and didn't didn't push me
too hard and and then I think you know
in my time as Jarrod's been a number of
times when Don's taken me aside and just
given me you know a sentence or two of
advice about you know how to you know
how to how to handle shall we say some
difficult situations in the department
and I greatly appreciate that so anyway
that's a little bit about my experience
with Don he's been you know a wonderful
colleague obviously a great scientist
and and you know a beloved figure here
at Stanford for a long time it's a great
pleasure to introduce him for the 24th
Christmas lecture
okay well thank you Alex I couldn't I
can't justify that all but let's get
let's get on with a whole bunch of
itself to say well I still see three
empty seats up here and a nice place to
sit on the floor for so you know unless
you plan to leave early okay so but the
title today is dancing links and and I
like I told my friend that I was going
to talk about dancing like I said Oh
didn't you talk about dancing links once
before and and and and sure enough I'd
forgotten about it but but in in 2000 in
February of 2000 I gave another one of
these toxic before this this particular
room was I was built and it was called
dancing links then and and and well you
know an awful lot has been learned since
then so I'm not going to repeat very
much what I said 18 years ago but but
you can still find it on the website of
si TN and you know just hey shouldn't be
too hard to do and and then you'll see
you know what the difference was the 18
years can make now
the next thing I want to show you is
this which is the which is the cover of
a book that I was hoping to get ready
for Christmas I saw that you know people
could could buy it however I kept into
discovering more and more stuff about
dancing links and so you know was never
time to finally wrap it so early next
year this will definitely be coming out
I have to
it's already it's already up to 350
pages and I at and I oh and I was gonna
you know these these little paperback
fascicles I was gonna try to keep the
limit at at the max of 300 pages but but
it it it actually comes before this one
this is the one that I published a
couple years ago and and and in this
these are eventually going to be this
will be the middle third and this will
be the first third of volume four be of
the art of computer programming in it
you know there's a vying for a so okay
so so I'm you know I'm still working on
it and and until I go see now like I
kicked in in to keep on chugging out
content and you know even though I can't
remember anymore what's what what's in
at all locally I have a good knowledge
of each page now and by the way that I
have this other book called selected
papers on fun and games which is a
really great book to give for Christmas
and in that book you can find picture
not only of one but two of Alex's
delightful children so another reason to
buy the book okay so now here we are
what is dancing links on tonight I'm
gonna I'm going to talk about a few
things that are technical but mostly its
Show and Tell mostly is things that I
you know that you can look up later if
you want to if you want to if you wanna
get more information but I'm not gonna
you know I'm not gonna really dumb it
down either by but by omitting where
what what the main point is but but
first plate dancing links is it it is an
extremely simple idea about about
something that a way to write a computer
program that is that is so simple that
you first you might yeah you might say
how could anybody talk for more than
five minutes about this this idea
however as I said I already 18 years ago
I talked an hour and a half about it and
and tonight don't you know like I'll try
to get into an hour and a half and so
what is it but so I got a first to
describe the idea then then something
about it but then on Glee lots and lots
of applications probably because it
turns out I the reason I haven't
finished this yet is because I keep
finding new is it's like at
Christmastime but I'm like I'm like a
kid with a new toy because I have I have
this this technology of dancing links
that I can use to solve problems that I
never thought I would solve in my
lifetime so it doesn't solve every
problem I mean it but it's completely
orthogonal to deep learning I don't
think any of the things I'm going to
talk about so so in the first place
it it it relies on I'm doubly linked
list because a version for singly linked
list but but links are links I'm
thinking about the you know the pointers
between the elements of the list and and
so you know we have a doubly-linked
let's suppose we have a doubly linked
list with with four nodes in it and we
can oh and then I with a doubly linked
list we usually also have a header node
so I'll call that zero one two three
forward zero is the header node and then
each it's doubly linked so zero so
everything points to its it's in
successor and and and the successor of
the the last guy is the is the head and
then everything also points to the
predecessor which so these but I already
I already that guy and this this comes
come come back in here so so so in
memory then if we had locations 0 1 2 3
4 and and we have
l linked and are leaked then a link of
our link of 1 of 0 is 1 and this is 2
this is 3 this is 4 this is 0 and then
going back 4 points - 3 - 2 - 1 - 0 + 2
4 ok so this is this is the way it looks
in memory when we have a doubly linked
list now okay so so one of the main
reasons why it's it's nice and lots and
lots of programs to have doubly linked
list is because we can delete a node
from the list
just knowing just knowing what node it
is we don't need to know how we got
there we can if we if we know the
address of a node P we can say delete P
so delete P is a very simple operation I
said L - L link of P and R - R Link of P
and then and then and then I said our
link of L R and L link of our to L so
that that wipes it out because the l was
the predecessor I was the successor and
now the predecessor points to the
success of this replace the predecessor
and that's it so this is did you know
this was kindergarten stuff but the
thing about dancing links is that I
don't know for 30 years whenever both
programs I thought okay now the good
thing is to do is is it gives up clean
up and and and reset the links of P you
know P is no longer in the list so I
returned it to to the pool of available
memory and and clean it up
however there's there are lots and lots
of applications where actually I know
that that everything I do I'm gonna want
to one
undulate Iran so so so many interactive
applications and the BACtrack
application like we were watching on
before the lecture when you're
backtracking you make a decision but
that's a tentative decision and then if
it was a wrong decision you backtrack
and you take and you undo and you go
back to where you were before the
decision so this is where we're what I'm
going to tell you about really shines
when we run doing something and so to
undo a deletion we would insert B and
for this o we say L goes to L link of
peak-hour goes to our link of P and then
we say our link of L is P and now what
could be simpler than this L link of our
is P so this obviously under under
undoes what I did before if I did this
right after that one so however I
wouldn't have been able to do this if I
had if I had garbage click if I had you
know been cleaned up my memory and and
and so so let's let's just let's just
take a look at it
suppose I suppose for example I delete
three from this list okay so I want to
you know I went three to go out and so
that says that L is 2 R is 4 so I have
to change this to 4 and I have to change
this to 2 okay so 3 is out now and and
and the Plitt suppose I also delete one
and so now I can eat 1 so 0 & 2 have to
change and so when this guy goes out I
have to change this to 2 and I have to
change this to 0 and suppose I delete 4
okay so I 2 and 0 I the predecessor and
successor now so I have to change this
to 0 and I have to change this deleted
though now undo so now let's say insert
4 let me before I before insert to
emphasize that the current status of
these links is really a mess what one of
the one of the main paradigms for
proving that a program is correct and
for knowing that that your algorithm is
working is is to talk is what we call
invariance of the data structure where
we say for every part of the data
structure what is it what does it mean
so what does L link mean what is our
link mean and we give some invariant
relation which is what you're supposed
to stay true all the way through our
computation and and and when I do
something like this the invariant
becomes hopeless you could you could
describe in logic but if that doesn't
correspond to anybody's intuition it's
so complicated nobody ever knew nobody
wants to bother writing down with us and
burying it so it it it it it opens up a
whole new way of proving that programs
are correct
you know I'm not saying invariants are
are bad I'm saying that they aren't
enough to prove this kind of algorithm
correct in the right way because but my
proof of correctness is operational
rather than this through logic I'm
saying I'm not gonna tell you what LD
can are like me all I'm gonna tell you
is if you do the if we do the insertion
operation in the opposite order then you
did the deletions you're gonna get back
what your head so I'm not telling you
what it means I'm telling you
operationally what it does and and and
that's that's convincing but but but
don't ever ask me to cut to prove this
this method correct by but by the old by
the old style of invariant ok now up so
except for then I look here at 2 and 0
and I said oh yeah ok
I mean I should have crossed these guys
oh but I can look at two and zero and I
and and and now you see I haven't erased
that so I still remember how what what
was the predecessor and successor of
four at that time so I can go back now
the two and I can change this back to
four and I can go back to zero in case
that back to four okay and and no I
don't have time to do but you know at
this point I could delete two and you
know and then you know then I could
insert to insert one and insert three
and and I'd be back to add to my
starting point but but but the
intermediate points don't ask me what
they what they were okay so now this as
I say is extremely good for well the
main point of it it is undoing and and
and one of the one of the sort of
corollary is don't don't don't clean up
your data all the time you know there
might be ya know some people leave it in
there only to see what you know
afterward if there was some hacker
attack how did it happen but but but
here there's a virtue in being sloppy so
okay now um take a look at the video
from 18 years ago in CTL I explained it
that day then okay now now one of the
most natural applications of this is for
a particular kind of problem that's
that's called the exact cover problem
and and and for the for for ten years
this was the only kind of problem that I
used to use dancing links for so closee
that cover problem is it one of the
traditional standard problems of
computer science that that the carp I
showed in the sixties is np-complete and
it's it's it's
I always used to think of it this way as
a have a matrix of zeros and ones and
here's a particular one that I've used
in in examples in my book I'm gonna
write two more lines here the the idea
of an exact cover problem is that you
have this matrix of zeros and ones and
we would choose some of the rows just a
few of the rows such a way that when we
add those rows up we get 1 1 1 and we
get exactly one every time time we do so
that's that's the goal like you know I'm
gonna have to choose either the second
row or the fourth row because I got to
have a 1 here so let's suppose that I
that I tried to choose the second row ok
so so that means I I've covered column
let me put names on these columns
ABCD efg so I've covered a and I've
covered D and I've covered he and so
that's just about only one decent way to
solve an exact cover problem and that is
to write is as to try a trial and error
you know try to try something something
and then see then you're left with an
exact cover problem that's that that's
simpler because you've already covered
some of the stuff so in this case we've
we've covered a and D and G and so all
we have to do all I have to do is look
at the other at the remaining columns in
the things that I haven't been that
haven't been done so for example this
one now now I got BC EF is left so I
have 0 1 1 0 and then this guy gives me
1:01 just when I can't use because it
clashes in in in a this one I can't use
because it clashes in G and this one I
can't use it clashes D and G so but it
we do so if I choose this guy then I
then I have to cover the other four
columns somehow out of these except that
I I didn't copy this very well this is a
one right certainly gonna be hard to cop
got cover B if there's no B if there's
no one's okay so but but still pretty
soon you see that there's no way to I
think to cover this because the you know
each each scene it interferes with the
other guy so that isn't going to work so
we're gonna have to backtrack and say no
I'm not going to choose this one I'm
gonna choose this one that's dead
alright now let let's pause for a minute
to look inside the computer because
because if we're using dancing links
okay let me show you let me show you
what I got what I got written so far so
this is a great this was a draft of the
UH what I couldn't got it online now
actually there's no link to it online
but but there are links there there are
links the classical five has three parts
to it and there are links to the first
part in the second part and the first
one is called fascicle 5a the second one
fascicle 5b so if you if you change that
link to fascicle 5c you're gonna you're
gonna get a look at this and and and in
in a month or so I'll I'll you know I'll
have a link to it because I still
haven't made the index to this and so
this is only for the people who are you
know really courageous
I can't wait but but now we get to the
oh by the way yeah there's a I'm not
gonna take time to zoom in
this but find any errors in this you get
256 it helps pay your tuition now so you
see the pictures of doubly linked lists
here and so on here's that very same
matrix and and here's the way it looks
in let's see I got to learn how to you
can learn this technology now I took it
hello I turned off the machine I hit the
power button - okay so yeah that's
that's it that's a little bit of a
danger okay so okay so sorry in my
memory like my book is is interfering
with the with the I have page numbers on
here I can get this back in order again
at the end here
okay so okay so this was the way it
looks in memory and and everywhere there
was a 1 in that matrix I've got a node
and then and there and the columns ABCD
efg are doubly linked so so everything
as a pointer instead - left and right it
has the pointer up and down and and in
in the in the columns themselves
there are also pointers to the left and
right so these guys have four links that
they have they're doubly linked
horizontally and vertically both and and
that's the list of columns that haven't
been covered yet but the but the
vertical is r2 all of the ways of
covering that that particular guy and in
the old days I also used to doubly
linked the
the guys you need individual rows of the
other matrix but that it turned out
those legs were never changing so there
was no point doing that I just just keep
it sequentially in memory so so I have
you know in 16 17 18 and then and then
he each possibility has a spacer node
before and after it that tells you how
to get to the end of the list or to the
beginning of the list
if you encounter a space or if you
counter space or note so so this is a
this is a faster data structure then I
had 18 years ago but but but the main
idea is that that I've got the exact
cover problem and it is sitting here as
a as a bunch of nodes and memory that
are they have links between them okay
now so if I decide to cover column a
that means that I'm going to and I'm
going to take out the theta structure it
everything every row that had a that has
something in a so I'm going to take out
this flank I'm going to take out this
line and it's insulting to I marks
through like from 12 I go to 13 I say
take 13 out so that's a delete operation
delete 13 trip from it it's it's totally
linked list delete 14 from this doubly
linked list and and similarly this one I
come in delete 2020 I'm gonna delete 21
and 22 from from their list okay so no
matter what I what I do to cover to
cover the a I'm gonna be deleting all of
these all these entries from live now
when I actually decide however to that
I'm going to try this one as the way to
cover a then I also have to have to
cover column D and cover column G as I
cover column D that's going to tell me
I'm going to have to delete just know 27
and I'm I'm sorry I'm gonna have to
delete the row that contains 27
Milwaukee and see what's still left in G
and I see these two guys and so I'm
gonna have to delete this line just this
one has already been deleted so they
throw anyway look at looking inside
following one link after another now you
see what you have to remove from these
lists later on when I'm going to undo
this operation I can know all of those
links that I looked at are still there I
haven't garbage collected away there
they're still sitting there and so later
on what I want to when I want to undo
this operation I can say oh I chose
eleven like yeah I looked at covering
Geo that means that I have to uncover G
and so it tells me oh yeah put this guy
back and you know I did my deletions
from left to right so unlike when I undo
I go from right to left but all of those
links are still sitting there so I
didn't have to store a single new thing
in memory in order to in order to undo
this complicated removing from this to
list and walk you through lists that
didn't exist before and in the end is it
the list jump back into place some like
opening a zipper or something just
before I need another link and it's
there and it's valid again so this is
the this is a way that that you can walk
through it an exact cover problem and
and and delete insert delete insert I
can in it and you never mess each other
up and it and it when you when you look
at it it just seems that that these
these these numbers in the computer are
following a elegantly choreographed
dance and so that's why I call it
dancing links and I'm still waiting for
somebody to write an app that takes us
algorithm and an exact cover problem in
it and and and somehow animates it so
that you can see this thing I mean as
I'm debugging I I watch it happening and
I marvel at it but I wish I had the good
videos
of the Prophet okay any questions about
this but the main point is that even
though the idea is extremely simple that
one operation obviously undoes the other
the fact that I that I didn't remove the
stuff for a memory means that I all the
scraps of information that I need to
take me back
are are there and they end and I keep
changing them and Nick and the ones I
needed a second last become available
after I've done the last and run down
the last etc etc okay so that's the
basic like a magical idea of dancing
like now so let's take a look at some
applications the easiest step well first
I want to mention that I I found out
that there's so many applications they
that and I guess I took I decided that
as the years went on I didn't want to
think of this exact cover problem
anymore as if it was a matrix of zeros
and ones I mean I I love zeros and ones
as a mathematician I played with
matrices of zeros and ones for years but
but it but it turned out to sort this
almost always a really sparse matrix and
it's much better if I had some other
some other way so instead of talking
about rows and columns I talked about
options and items and so that these ABCD
efg I call these items of my problem and
and then the various ways to cover the
items I call options so we have options
and and for example the first option is
C II and the second option is ad eg and
the third option is BC the fourth option
a D F and two more options be B G and D
eg okay so so instead of instead of
presenting my data as eros and ones I
using it instead in a text file as lines
of options and and the the things in the
option are I call items okay so now I
can actually talk about problems in
which in which items are rows instead of
columns for you know sometimes the
terminology for all applications of
exact covered problem it will change
from application to application but but
in every case the word option has worked
that well and the word item has worked
that well for the for the way to present
it so let's look so that the very simple
exact cover problems are the ones where
there's only two items in every option
if there's only one item in an option
that's even simpler but that's so
trivial you know they the main
interesting one so I start with when we
have at least two items per option and
the case where there's only one actually
they we have a shortcut to handle so and
those are exactly the problems that
everybody knows under the name of a
perfect matching in graphs if you have
two items in an option you could think
of that as a graph with were that's an
edge between those two items and and so
if we want to choose we've included
we've even you know covered every vertex
exactly once that collection of edges
were every vertex that that's called a
perfect matching Emma graph and in
general I'll make it two zeros and once
it is it's called a hyper graph and the
rows of a hyper graph are called the
hyper edges and so this exact cover
problem is the same as the problem of
getting a perfect matching in a hyper
graph okay so the the the case of
ordinary graph where this was to one of
the one of the most beautiful examples
of a perfect matching problem is it is
called the
if it's a problem made popular by Edwin
Lucca in in 19th century and they call
it the blending mean I this is the
problem of couples and and and so if you
look at Wikipedia you get a very
beautiful picture about this problem the
Mach panache the idea is you have you
have n male-female couples and you want
to sit them at a circular table so in
this picture n is five we got ten seats
at the table and and the rule is that
has to alternate male female male male
female and nobody sits next to their
spouse so so how many ways are there to
not to solve the problems in our in this
in this case there's also a problem of
how do you get a pink napkin for this
place over here but it's a nice picture
and and this is a you know really kind
of a nice practical problem you know
people face it all the time if they have
a circular table and and also you know
there's beautiful mathematics goes with
it what more could you ask but let's
take a look at it as I would set it up
as an exact covered problem to my like
to my solvers so so I have a bunch of
solvers that I that I called DLX some of
you will know DLX as the as the name of
them of the of the machine that
Hennessey and Patterson use in their in
their book on architecture I had em IX
and they wanted it also to have a
machine that that was Roman numerals so
DLX is it is 560 and mi X is a thousand
and nine but anyway now DLX
is it is actually the deal
for dancing links here and x4 exact
cover and and and so here's here's a
example data file and it's produced by a
program called Minaj DLX with the
parameter five and and at first it
states the item so the first line of a
file input to a DLX other states all of
the items and here I have items SCORM
share with us for and for their there
are there are five seats that have to be
covered and there are five men that have
to be covered I'm going to assume that
the women have already been seated
somehow you know no matter how we solve
the problem we're going to have women
are going to occupy these alternate seat
so let's suppose that that that we that
you know there's lots of ways to there's
two in factorial ways to do that but but
let's suppose that's already been done
because nope no matter what happens we
have to solve this residual problem
after the women are seated so here we
have then you know I have W 0 the women
are already sitting there but but there
are five seats between them s0 s1 s2 and
so on and and and and then I've got to
cover the five seats and I have to also
cover them with five men m0 m1 and so
these are the people and now what are
the options so we got these ten options
to cover of the the I'm sorry the items
ten items to cover but but the option
the first option is s0 M ones that
without you know man one consider man
zero can't sit there man man for can't
sit there because because they're not
allowed to sit next to your right so so
so s 0 M 1 s 0 M two and three are the
options for s 0 then there's options for
s 1 and so on so and I call this with
these options in any order but but these
are the possible these are the
possibilities for the exact cover
problem and and and so you know make a
doubly linked list inside the computer
for this
let me okay
you see where I am in my and so feed it
to myself or and out come the answers
and so it turns out there's there's
thirteen solutions to this problem and
let's just take a look at a tip of one
solution number eight number eight so
this says s 0 M 0 this was two of three
ways to cover s 0
so we've already tried you know the
first way and and here it is it works s
one mm4 then that this one says M 3 s 2
instead of s 2 and 3 it meant that at
this point it says one of one it meant
after I've seeded as 0 after I've seeded
M 2 here and M 4 here there's only one
place for em three to go so he chose not
to cover one of the esses but the it
looks at every item there's no
difference between the M items and the s
items the one that has the fewest
possibilities is the one that worked
that that we that we try to cover neck
and so that's the way this particular
solution came out so let's say there 13
solution and and how did how did I get
that well for example here I I try I
tried for three four five six seven
eight nine ten couples each case I I
called my menage DLX
to generate the data and then I if I fed
it into the DL x1 solver for exact cover
and then I said okay echo statements
like I can separate these out so here's
the
first of all you know three men three
women there's three options of six items
nine total entries among the items
because there's three operatives and
nine entries but there should be but
there should be six so what did I do
that's interesting why does that say
nine entries I have to check that out
okay hmm now with four couples we had
eight options with five couples we had
fifteen options and it seems to think
there are three entries each instead of
two for each option so they so that
there's off by one somehow there
probably counts something for the space
or I don't know why okay so so we get
thirteen solutions with five we get
eighty solutions we get hot five minutes
every night when there are ten couples
439,000 and some solutions how long did
it take to find these solutions and all
of the algorithms in my book I I could
tell you how many seconds it took but
but that wouldn't mean anything next
year because it because computers keep
changing from year to year so instead I
count how many references to memory were
made and and and that's not going to
change I mean you can know you can
change the algorithm and find another
you know find a better way but this
particular method it is gonna it's gonna
it's gonna read or write memory a
certain number of times and and it turns
out that for example in this ten couple
case about a hundred and eighty memory
references per solution so it's piping
out these I have to do much computation
between solutions these solutions are
generated internally and they could have
been piped to a file or something if I
wanted to but but in this case I only
counted okay
like any questions like that
yep find a signal with someone a lot of
them that's no comparison with other
algorithms yeah yeah I'll get you some
of that quick but because of course this
is if this is a general purpose of
solver and and when you get to perfect
matching problems there's all kinds of
different ways to solve a perfect
matching problems as we know it's not
you know it's not a it's not real tight
but but it and there are some problems
that there are more cash friendly and
others obviously but but this yet you
know I write about five new problems a
week and it's been pretty stick steady
for the last ten years the number of men
but you know but if but if I did but but
but I in my book the Stanford graph base
I have I compared the six algorithms or
something for minimum spanning tree and
and they used caches in different ways
and so the cost of a member per
microsecond was was definitely different
in different algorithms yeah okay good
question I've got to move on to dancing
mixes so this DLX ever and I'm talking
about it is on the web if there's dl x 1
dl x 2 and so on and and you can
download them from my home page and it's
there it's not surprisingly written in
in see web which is my favorite
programming language interact and you
got all the code in here it starts out
with the in fact an example to the same
example and explains the you know the
input data and in the various bells and
whistles you have for for running is the
big part of the big part of the program
is just inputting the thing into the
doubly linked list in the first place
then then we get some
the actual covering oh so here's the
cover subroutine and it does the
doubly-linked lists and you know that
does a deletion here and and then
there's an uncover which does the
insertion operation and so on so that's
the program that you can take a look at
now among the bells and whistles I can
say for example well here I tried it out
on 16 on 16 couple so when I was 16 and
I DLX won it and I my first parameter is
M 1 billion and so just show me every
book every billion solution and then T 1
billion it says stop after you found a
billion solutions and then s says this
is randomized
what women when you're choosing between
different options to scramble the lists
and and do it randomly and and see if
that makes a difference and this is the
seed for a random number generator if I
change this seed I would get another
okay and then okay so now standard by
default is is that every ten every 10
billion mems
it gives me a status report when you're
when you're running a combinatorial
problem like you don't like to just sit
there and say ok you want to know how I
was doing you know and and so about
every 20 seconds this meet this was
right now on my computer at home if
that's that twenty seconds is about 10
billion men's ok and so it it had found
what 52 million solutions to during
those four first twenty second and and
then it and then it said well at the top
level it it's doing case one of 14 1 e
the e is hexadecimal so case one at 14
after you know there were 14 ways to
cover see Journal probably and then
after I did that that there were 13 ways
to cover some other seat and then twelve
ways and then so I'm still working on
the first by the time I but by the time
I come down here I I'm still on the
first choice for for the first option
and covering this one but then I'm out
to the ninth choice of of this guy and
and so you can watch this and you can
see how far you are and also there's a
number at the end it tells you
percentage-wise how far have I gone
so at this point I'm up 2.000 through
now actually the number of solutions to
the Manoj problem is very close to n
factorial divided by E squared Y squared
is is between seven and eight and so
this is you know one out of every six
between one out of every seven one out
of every eight permutation actually
works for this problem of seating people
without being next to their spouses and
and so I know if you work out what 16
factorial it's it's I think it's 21
trillion and so you divide that by 7 you
get 3 to 3 trillion suppose about three
treys solutions like that and I said you
know stop after the first billion so
there's any way that that's where we are
okay now and yeah it would it would
grind them out and that you know I'd
have a middle of the day if I really
wanted and and the without randomization
did this was this was going at at 190
MEMS per solution no I'm sorry
yeah 192 192 billion men in order to get
tender in solution so or what 1 billion
solutions and so that's 192
but but it would have been hundred
seventy-five if I hadn't if I had used
randomization at every step that's you
know I had to generate random numbers it
takes ok so there's an example of how I
use this I'm one of the simplest
problems that's the simple problem all
the ways of a perfect magic let me go
night next to it a classic problem of
computer science the one we were
watching on the movie before came in and
the problem of n-queens you were trying
to put queens on a chess board the
classic problem we have it have ordinary
chess board and eight queens and we and
so I want to get eight eight Queens on
the board so that neither Queen attacks
another one and and so now I set this up
with another program called Queens DLX
eight to get the 8 Queens problem and
and it sets up it sets up the items are
for C for this is a Rankine column on
the chess board and and I put them in
this order starting in the middle of the
board and going to the edges because it
it's a little faster to decide on on the
on the Queen's in the middle but but the
interesting thing is that rows and
columns are symmetrical to all of the
textbook solutions to this problem go go
row by row you first put a queen in row
0 then Rwanda some room or other and and
you try different columns but but in
this case you know sometimes it's better
to cut to choose a column because that
because there's only a few ways left too
few empty spaces left in that column so
instead of going row by row the this
approach by options doesn't distinguish
between between this but then they have
this vertical bar here so there's
secondary items coming out from the
vertical bar secondary items you don't
have to cover them but to put your
allowed only to cover them at most once
instead of exactly one and so so a
secondary item these are for the
in the Queen's problem I've got I've got
eight rows and I've got eight columns
but I've also got shift that fifteen
diagonals going this way and fifteen
diagonals coming this way and and and so
there's an option for example are to see
five say seven ba this is this is our to
c5 b b b 10 and a seven so it says that
i can't occupy a diagonal more than once
but but I had but but I don't have to
occupy an diagonal exactly what okay so
they so this is a yes in this case some
of the options have only three items but
most of them have four items and and so
that's the so the entry from another
nice example of exact cover and so here
I tried it for up to 16 queens 8 8 Queen
up to 16 Queen and so it we eight queens
it there's always 92 solutions and so I
already get up to when I get to 16
queens I can solve them all by default
it gives me this progress report after
every 10 billion men so I got here I was
in case 4 of 16 cases after after after
10 billion were finally at the end it
took a minute and 16 seconds to get all
of the you know 15 million solutions to
the 16 Queens problem and and this
compares favorably to special-purpose
rooms that that are written of course
they the world champions solution to the
N Queens problem gosh I forget exactly
how far they got but anyway that they
built an FPGA series and so on I think
things massively parallel squeezed
everything okay next problem you might
recognize this was in the Palo Alto
weekly week we can go Friday
and I I gotta talk about pseudo cool
because this is one of the great simple
things to do with this with this exact
cover algorithm so so pseudo cool people
some people say it's it's it's the most
popular recreation in the world at the
moment anyway this was the problem we
had in last week's weekly sort so here
it is as a I have like a pseudo cool
deal X and it puts out a whole bunch of
items here I didn't list them all but
but there's that there's an item for
every empty cell there's an item for
every row that every number that hasn't
appeared in in a row or a column or a
bus so if we take a look at for example
these these two options here can you see
that this is a p85 r81 see 50 what this
this option corresponds to putting a 1
in in it in in row 8 in column 5 I'm
numbering from 0 so that would that
would that would be the bottom row and
in this column so that would that would
be like putting one right here and the
next option is is for putting a 7 in
that in that place because I would say
you know cover put something in p85 that
put you put your 7 in row a put your 7
in column 5 and put your 7 in box number
7 so that would be one of the options
and after I've solved the problem I'm
gonna have exactly one option for for
p85 I'm gonna have what exactly one
option for r87 I'm gonna have one option
where I grew up where I chose a 7 in
this row I'm gonna have one option or
I'd chose a 7 in this column and one
option where a total 7 in this box okay
so so exactly other problems
so this this cruise to victory
incredibly fast so if you look at the
solution to the problem it it said well
there's only one way to cut to fill p33
and after you filled that then there's
only one way to do forty three and so on
there was only one choice I said that
there would never you never never had
that you know I had to stop and think
long had to do is it in fact that
particular problem
there was also only one way to put a
three in column what in Row one or or in
in row five or only one way to put a
four in column one and so on they were
all kind of force moves you know waiting
for you to do so it turns out that if
you look at you over the years I like
you know I'm an airline it look at a
magazine or I seen the London Times or
wherever I'm like every once a while
like I took a sample of this little goo
problem that they were doing and range
from problems that were called you know
diabolical and and impossible and so on
and and and I never found one that
needed a search tree of more than 280
nodes and it's almost always almost
always a really really fat even with the
with the with the limited heuristic so
better in here well I got a lot more to
talk about those like can't dwell on it
but I do want to mention that that
should silikal is such a popular problem
I do I do have some pages about it and
and here's a for example a problem where
the clues are three one four one five
nine two six five three five eight nine
you know it has the first 33 digits of
pi and and you'll since my pseudo GU
suffers so fast it was wasn't hard to
interactively do this I thought this was
this was an original idea but that but I
learned earlier this year that that your
Honda rudder
had already done this five or six years
ago Johanna are you here tonight yeah oh
here you are yeah okay so and I thought
he lived in Netherlands but but but but
but I got to meet him a couple months
ago so so I think you know that over the
years whenever I have to have to choose
an example in my books like I try to
base it on PI if I can and the next one
here is three one four one five nine it
doesn't it's not perfect but it has only
17 clues in it and and it's known that
that every trudeau cool with a unique
solution you know you need at least 17
clue
and so this one has only 16 and so it's
got to have two solutions but it turns
out that it doesn't use either a 7 or 8
anywhere and so those two solutions are
exactly the same except that you switch
seven and eight okay so anyway lots of
interesting fun things to do about
Suzaku and I discuss how it corresponds
with this dancing makes algorithm and
there's there's there's big saucer Doku
which is where I instead of having three
by three boxes you can have the boxes be
arbitrary size and here it turns out ok
here's PI giving a unique solution with
big sizes oh all right but exact cover
problems go you know to many many other
cases and one of the one of the first
that I knew about were were problems
like polyominoes how many people have
heard of pentominoes oh we got one out
of four okay so this was all this this
was all arranged in the 60s taking these
shapes and comparing them interesting
how many people know about the soma cube
not as many so the soma cube is a three
dimensional toy we're supposed to pack
these seven pieces into a three by three
by three cube and this was set this was
such a popular pot I mean there were
more than two million soma cubes in
America alone in 1970 this was you know
before rude rubik's cube this was the
cue and I thought my my set here tonight
but I don't have time to anyway I'm very
proud of this because I got it in
Denmark is beautiful rosewood pieces and
and just as I was setting up on the desk
here I found out that this one came
apart
but anyway but not it it's actually how
can I say it's it's a pleasure to play
with these things and and so one of the
greatest mathematicians John Conway
spent a lot of time figuring all kind of
neat things out about so my and also
these have let have lessons in general
for exact cover problems because as I
point out in the next two pages by
reasoning about there are a lot of
tricks you can apply to exact cover
problems to to simplify it and throw out
a lot of options and so in particular
for that for the soma cube it turns out
that you can prove for example that that
that this piece has to go on on an edge
and so without loss of generality you
could start and put this here and any
solution can be rotated so that this is
on the bottom so that's it and it's a
general the general principle about
about comma torial problems in general
that did I call factory okay now but
gotta keep moving so let's go on to to
do some a cube III have items are the
different pieces and the different cells
and so the different options are to say
aw use piece W and fill cell 2 1 2 2 1 3
2 2 2 all these options and and so let's
go to another kind of problem and this
was well let's see I got I got in here
there was one of the one of the great
masters of combinatorial mathematics was
major Percy but man of the Royal
Artillery and he was was the greatest
call me total mathematician in the early
20th century and that in 1892 he has
this he had this patent on a game last
he was playing a new kind of game and
and basically he had he had 24 triangles
and each triangle was numbered 0 1 2 or
3 in it you could think of this as as
four colors on the edges of the
triangles and yet and he wanted to put
these 24 trials together so that Ed was
matched together and and he became
president of the London mass society and
in any way 1921 came out with this book
about mathematical pastimes and one of
them was his his problem
uh-uh not on triangles but on squares so
again he has 24 squares and this time
there's three colors instead of four but
but there's exactly 24 different ways to
color the edges with three colors up
with three given colors and then then he
puts them together so I got another I
got another set of tiles here this is
these are this is for McMahons 24 things
it's arranged with a here in the 5x5
grid instead of a 4 by 6 but but the
four by six problem was the one that had
banded and I mentioned it because it has
an interesting connection to Stanford a
is one of the very first one of the very
first reports of the Stanford artificial
intelligence project is number number 12
in 1964 and I believe it was the first
large computation ever taken at
Stanford's AI department documentation
of the McMahons squares problem and so
he sets it up and he has a computer
program and to count how many solutions
there were and it program ran for 40
hours and and he says right here total
of 112 thousand 261 solutions exist and
so this number 12,000 261 was quoted in
lots of publications throughout the
sixties it turned out that it was wrong
and and and in in 1977 a man in
Argentina he's actually the rector of a
Technical College in Buenos Aires
recomputed it and got about 4,000 more
solutions this program has had long gone
so I have no we have no idea what the
bubble or bugs were in this program but
I had to mention it you know as a piece
of history well it sets up very very
nicely as a
but not as an exact cover problem of the
normal kind so here's a very important
point I'm extending does that cover
problem
to something where I had sayings that
cover problem with colors or with color
controls and so this this is really what
I want to show you especially this new
this new kind of a combinatorial problem
well it's it's not exactly new but it
but it's a try explain why I think it's
it's important so I so it it goes beyond
what I said before so the items from
American mask
where's problem there's item for each
cell and there's an item for each kind
of thing but then I have after the line
I had these secondary items and I have a
secondary item for the each horizontal
edge in each vertical edge in the
diagram and now the and now with this
new kind of problem which I call an xcc
problem that's the exact covering with
color constraints X you see I if you
think of a better name we might be might
not be too late to change it but anyway
X you see has been working for me for
the last three years
so X you see problem says for every
secondary thing I can give a color to it
and and and that means that you can use
the secondary item more than once with
with the Queen's problem I was only
using the diagonal items what most ones
but but I didn't give him colors it was
this like every in every option of that
problem is if I had a new color for
every option but this time you know I
can say this secondary item a vertical
line number zero zero is color a and and
this secondary item is color a in this
second alright and so for the different
options I have are to take one of what
one of the pieces like the BBB a piece
and and I can rotate at different ways
and put in this particular place in
there and that gives colors to these
things so the rule is on the on the
primary items you have to cover a
primary other than exactly once
on the secondary item I like you you're
allowed at most one cup you can use the
second I am is more than once but if you
do they all have to have the same color
and that's that's that's through Forex
EC problems now I didn't realize until a
year or so ago that I think it was year
and a half ago
how how widely III kept solving more and
more problems that ecstasy problem but I
didn't realize how how gentle it was
into and so I want to convey some of
that to you tonight by example and so
one example I have in my book is it is
is based on another popular recreation
that you find in that you find in
magazines and newspapers how many people
know word search problems that we see
word search puzzles we got a few okay so
so on page 23 of my thing I got just
problem here find the mathematicians so
to put ovals around the names where they
appear in this fifteen by fifteen or a
table Bertrand Borel Cantor hensel's or
mate and so on you know the and they can
appear either left to right like here's
Catalan or they can appear right to left
and they can pair diagonally up it up or
down so they're eight ways they a name
can appear and and I say here take a
break before reading any further spend a
minute or two solving this puzzle and
because then you'll get the idea for why
this is a natural for exact rubbing this
color okay so on the next page there's a
solution
look at that Catalan and Londa or both
there here's autumn art that's now the
question is of course not how to solve
this problem just put this puzzle you
know is just determine you just go
scanning it you know it's a sort of
no-brainer you just have to
after look a path eight passes for
example but uh but the car means how do
you design the puzzle how do you pack
all these all these names in here so so
for example let's suppose like suppose I
have a six five six array and I want to
and I want to fill this this array with
with with twelve with twelve words o ne
T wo th are eating a one-two-three-four
spelled out all the way up to twelve and
so for example here's 12 at the Barbican
can you read that there TW e lv that
tonight and six is there but if you know
eleven is up here so I had to pack all
of those words into a six by six array
how could I do it and and also with one
space left over and so I set this up as
a you have a problem that a a driver
that takes any word search for six five
six here and and fits in a dot for the
empty space and then one two three and
puts it in how do you do it well it's
just you know it's just a color problem
where I have to I have to cover one
because I have to have a one summer what
that's one of the options is to put it
here here and here
alright so for each option that I have
for putting in ona that there's a line
here it ends similarly for forty w8o and
as long as the colors don't conflict
I'll get a solution for this so besides
weird besides these weird search
problems there's also with word cross
problems so well that's exercise 185
let's see here so here here's an example
where I where I I packed a one two three
like you know zero and here's zero up to
know but hero that they're different
rules that they all have to read like
in a crossword puzzle I left the writer
you know cross her down
enjoy and I'm not allowed to yeah I have
a space between words and things like
that
another packing problem as it turns out
sure enough that packing problem can be
done with a xec problem here is other so
I have you know I have I have different
items that has to be covered and then
the and then the different ways the
zeros and ones say do I have a space
here or not or a letter okay so that was
that's complicated but it's a it's there
if you in the book if you want to see so
not only let me go to what I
many people consider sort of the the
most important class of combinatorial
problems they called CSP problems a
constraint satisfaction problem and and
constraint the model for katraine
satisfaction problem is that trick that
you're given a bunch of variables in
different domains and you're given
relations between the variables that
have to be satisfied and so there's you
know many conferences are organized
around CSP there's journals devoted to
CSP and the same model of CSP also is
its equivalent to the model of drawings
in databases and it's equivalent to
physicists models of interaction between
molecules and things like this so it's
it it took it's a very general problem
it turned out to be a a special case of
the xec problem so let me let me try to
explain here's easy CSP a constraint
satisfaction problem let's say the
variables are ABCDEF each variable his
turn area has a domain 0 1 2 the first
constraint is that a B and C have to be
sick in cyclic order also DNF the third
constraint is he has to be less than or
equal D and fourth constraint a less
than D so now let's set this up
in xec problem a line that begins here
is a comment so so constraint one says
that a is 0 B is 1 co2 or there are 3
ways to fulfill constraint 1 and I look
at those are three options here a B and
C are cyclic there are three options for
D D and F they're cyclic there's six
options for C and D because C is less
than or equal D so C they could be 0 0 0
1 0 2 and so on and and fourth
constraint a less than e ok so that's in
general when people have CSP that they
they have ways of abbreviating
constraints and sort of saying that
these are all different or things like
this and there are also tricks to encode
that with the ecstasy but but in general
you see that the the sort of generic CSP
is a special case of this coloring
problem and the options are a very
particular kind each option has only one
primary item and all of the secondary
items for that primary are in the same
exact same variables exact same second
item so there's an extremely small class
of Ecstasy problems exactly covers all
of the CSP part in that sense okay so
now here's another another example for
well I'm gonna help I'm gonna have to I
do it faster but one of the classical
problems of of computer science is it's
called the comm unit or existence define
a de bruyne sequence and and this is a
sequence of zeros and ones that contains
as its subsequences it contains every
possible
Interpol and and you can generalize that
and say yeah page 20 I talked about X
ECU we can go beyond X you see as well
and instead of saying that I have to
cover every primary item exactly once I
can also I can also say no let's let's
cover it a range of times let's say that
that the first primary item should be
covered either once or twice the next
one exactly five times the next one once
through eight times and things like this
so so I call this an MCC problem this is
a this is a problem with color
constraints and multiplicity and and one
example of this is what's called the the
Partridge problem because because Bob
Wainwright was singing on the on the
twelfth day of Christmas my true love
gave to me and he had various partridge
in a pear tree and and and so he said
well it turns out that that the sum of
the first n cubes is the square of the
sum of the first n numbers which says
that I should be able to take a one by
one and two two by twos and three three
by threes and so on and an N by ends and
put them together in a square and and it
turns out you can't do that until until
n is eight
but here's an example where you have
eight eight eight eight five squares and
seven seven by seven squares and cyclic
so on
he called this his partridge problem and
you can solve this very nice he has an
MCC problem by saying that the that you
cover the eight guys eight times instead
of once so so I also could be good
gaming like de Bruyne sequences so then
I so I have a sequence that turn out
this problem have 550-thousand solutions
but three the first solution I want to
get all all four tuples in such a way
that that if there's if there's one one
in the fourth puzzle that occurs once if
there's two tools that occurs twice and
so on so here's here's a thirty two
cycle 0 0 0 1 and so on repeats three
thirty two times starting at 0 I get 0 0
0 i starting at 1 i guess there was a
100 here I listed different times and so
if something has two ones in it occurs
twice the cycle it has three ones that
occurs three times it's like very easy
to set this up as a MCC problem and we
get all the 50,000 answer well I see
that I can way over time so I got a I
just got to show you may be either gig
save this the next Christmas I don't
know but but but I had so much you know
I have so many things I wanted to do
show-and-tell so well I'm just going to
go through quickly now and just just
show you because all of these problems
we use xec of mostly and sometimes MCC
and and so that's why I say I was like a
kid playing with a new toy and so I'm
going to just let run through quickly
now and and you can go online and look
at it any of these that you're
interested here for example are
are some word problems where I got like
onward stairs and this is a cyclic
arrangement of words so that you can
read them across it or you could read
them down it and it makes words both
both ways and and and here I could do it
so you can you can make the stair go
this way or the stifle this way and here
you use the same words and either way so
you get different words but it all works
that that's it easy SCC from exercise
178 well this was a application to music
if you want to compose beautiful music
Bob Dylan system okay I talked about
McMahan problems but there's but there's
but that was that's just the beginning
[Applause]
for example that goes a set of is a set
of 24 tiles that McMahon didn't think of
that
that turns out to make some really
fascinating problems that you can you
can match edges vertices instead of
edges and that gives you some really
tough problem here you can match both
vertices and edges you can also use
hexagonal grids there's three
dimensional matching of faces on cubes
on page 83 I have more about the end
Queen
[Applause]
so besides besides finding all solutions
it turns out that oh I forgot to mention
a DL X 2 which does this this coloring
problem is almost the same as the LX 1 I
could use all that code and just add a
couple more subroutines to put on this
color constraint but then there's DL x5
which which also says find the minimum
cost solution so instead of finding all
solution finds
solution that minimizes some cost and
for each option you give it a costume
and chooses options that have that
flawless total cost and so here I took
in Queens and I gave a cost saying
putting a queen somewhere
what's the distance from the center and
so you find the solution to that problem
or the longest distance or the in this
case the shortest if you take the nth
power of the distance and go to infinity
that then you get these patterns which I
believe are the most beautiful some
delightful piece is called windmill
dominoes there's ten of them we take an
ordinary Domino and you put a half-size
Domino at 45-degree angle above it and
then there are lots of fascinating
things that actually can do to put them
together
so that so that for example you get a
path for both colors in this case it
gives you a good path on the top but not
on the bottom here it gives you a good
but good pass on the bottom but not a
loop on the top but but if you're clever
you can get loops on both sides then
there's problems about Mondrian dividing
rectangles into rectangles and then I
finish it with with puzzles that that
appear in in lots of books and magazines
first of all there's there's food Oh
cheeky which and then there's Ken Ken
and there's slither link and there's
Matthew all of these are artists as
fascinating as pseudo cool and probably
more and there's kid dot this is Carol
and this is a hippo and victori
anyway these are all
I like to think that these pages contain
the best write-ups ever made of those
seven puzzled but anyway yep it was it
was great fun to to write about all and
they all involve PI somehow okay well
here I am eight o'clock so time to go I
and wish you all a Merry Christmas but
but I hope I explained to you why I it
take me so long to to finish this this
particular part of art of computer
programming but I really think that that
you know the DLX hours that your honor I
can't see why you guys did this isn't
going to become kind of a you know a new
thing the old you know there's already
billion dollar industry for CSP but this
goes a lot further and it seems to have
lots of potential so I'm kind of feel
that I'm I'm trying to eat trying to
introduce it and and I it looks like it
might have a really bright future from
people having better and better DLX
hours as time goes on
thanks for your patience
don't feel bad about walking out but I
want to take it just one question anyway
and then I can handle other questions
afterwards so who's who's got a question
that they wouldn't mind having online
there are some that that are obviously
more more addictive than other but but
but the ones that I you know you know I
gave them the seven out yeah and Nicoli
has encyclopedia of 200 puzzles okay and
took but I took the ones that are that
are most popular but also most different
because each of those seven used a
different technique so I learned
something with each week with each of
those I know there was another thing
that I could do with actually see that I
didn't know I could do okay thanks a lot
you